you may have heard of chat GPT the
stagnance of these two characters is
what propels each respective plot
forward and changes those around them a
new artificially intelligent chat bot
that you can command to write pretty
much any text existentialism exists as a
refusal of the notion of Our Lives
having some predetermined reasoning you
also may have heard that chat GPT is so
good and writes so much like a human
that
to write essays and do homework
assignments an existential text with its
themes of individuality freedom and the
search of meaning of life
so yes I pulled to Billy Madison and
went back to AP Literature to see how
far Ai and just AI could get me I'm a
new student
totally in high school I enrolled in
12th grade at High Tech High School in
Secaucus New Jersey
okay fine the teacher Michael Diamond
let me in his class since he had already
been playing around with the AI tool and
was intrigued by my cheating experiment
I have a quick question yes is the Wi-Fi
down the Wi-Fi is down great thanks
sorry so did chat gbt pass or fail we
devised two challenges to find out
challenge number one write an essay
before coming to class Mr Diamond
emailed me my assignment in a 500 to
1000 word essay compose an argument that
attempts to situate Ferris Bueller's Day
Off as an existentialist task the
assignment also said to make explicit
comparisons or connections between
Ferris Bueller's Day Off and the
metamorphosis by Franz Kafka I edited
the assignment text slightly pasted it
into chat GPT and in about a minute I
had it a full essay I was impressed it
drew parallels to Gregor the main
character in kafka's book and to Ferris
it had varied scented structure and good
grammar and was decently organized I put
it in a document and submitted it to Mr
Diamond via email then he did his thing
[Music]
ended up with a three out of six on the
AP rubric I was a little generous
because it's early in the year you
showed some promise but there are some
issues you really need to work on you
got your thesis point right away you
wrote Ferris Bueller's Day Off is a film
that can be interpreted as an
existentialist text with its themes of
individuality freedom and the search for
meaning in life unfortunately in that
same opening paragraph you misattributed
a line that was said by Cameron to
Ferris you sure of that that I am sure I
am not going to sit on my ass
as the events that affect me unfold to
determine the course of my life I'm
going to take a stand there were other
factual inaccuracies in my essay Chachi
PT confused Cameron with Ferris saying
Ferris was reserved and rarely seen next
to his peers I think maybe you were you
were thinking of Cameron but you wrote
Ferris uh yeah I think that's probably
what I was thinking yeah you said that
the setting of The Metamorphosis was
Suburbia which it was not it was an
urban setting no we need to work on
being more accurate in your details and
I did not see a lot of vivid writing
here not easy for a professional
journalist and writer to hear the
overall quality of your writing puts you
in the lower 30th percentile I think you
may have the mind to get there but it's
the skills that you need to work
to work it doesn't feel good challenge
one a pass because technically a three
out of six on an AP essay is like a b or
a c I should note that plagiarism
detectors like this one from grammarly
are not likely to flag AI writing as
plagiarism since it is original text do
you think you would have had any idea
this was written by a computer I don't
think that I would catch it to be honest
I mean first of all if you look at the
actual context of when I'm grading right
I'm going through 60 of these at a clip
and I'm looking for specific things
luckily for Mr Diamond companies are
working on ways to detect AI writing
Challenge number two participate in a
group discussion you're gonna get into
core groups and you're going to go
through the next three steps and you're
going to first
review the story each group has been
assigned one in advance my group was
assigned to read Dennis Johnson's short
story car crash while hitchhiking from
The Collection Jesus's son my groupmates
immediately got to the first discussion
question about the characters if the cop
did actually stop him to make sure he
actually was you know a part of the
crime scene could you also say maybe the
doctor or is that yeah
when I search chat gbt for information
about the main character in the story
the bot said it didn't have any at all
so I changed the prompt and asked it
questions about the collection's title
Jesus's son which kinda got me somewhere
is there a character named Billy
yeah not in this chapter anyone in this
chapter have anything to do with
addiction yes oh yes yes okay and does
he attempt to navigate the complexities
of Life yeah yes
okay but that was really all I could
contribute I tried different prompts
like what's the bigger philosophical
question but I got no help
while openai the company behind chat gbt
trained this tool on a massive Trove of
data gathered from the internet and
other sources it clearly hasn't read
this book finally I just tried to skim
the text but ultimately I just asked a
very nice human to summarize it for me
basically this guy has been like
traveling traveling through he's been
like hitchhiking through like the woods
and everything challenge two fail
of course the whole purpose of this
experiment wasn't really to try to get
an A in AP Lit but to see the
capabilities and limits of AI as an
educational tool so some have started to
call this cheat GPT are you worried
about that I am worried about the
easiness right that's what cheating
really is is like the easiest way to do
a thing they're not learning what I'm
asking them if the internet can give
them a full essay because they're
missing out on the process of writing
right I'm more concerned with the
possibilities to prevent learning and
beget compliance so they can get pushed
through school so to speak my biggest
takeaway returning to high school 20
years after graduating how in Grain Tech
already is
students already lean on Google and
grammarly and more to help them with
their assignments it's nuts to think
artificial intelligence won't be the
next tech to change education I am
definitely going to try to figure out
how to use it I feel like with All Tech
it's easy to be scared of it and the
good news is at least here there's some
teachers that I've been talking with
that are like excited about getting
ahead of it and incorporating it and not
running from it because I don't think
we're going to outrun it
hi guys
can you be my friend
foreign